au début du mois de mars schyle en gare
aussi tombe malade et se retrouve
brièvement l'hôpital elle reçoit alors
un diagnostic d'infection à la copie 19
pendant son isolement à la maison ces
symptômes semblent s'estomper
ok mouvement après la période
d'isolement prescrite
elle reprend donc ses activités normales
pendant ce temps des membres de sa
famille y compris sa soeur présentent à
leur tour des symptômes de lakovic 19
puis la surprise
quelques semaines plus tard et se sent à
nouveau malade et reçoit un résultat de
test positif
c'est un mystère pour nous tous dit-elle
craignant avoir été réinfectés par des
membres de sa famille
de rares cas de réinfection été
rapportés en chine ou au japon
il pourrait aussi s'agir d'une rechute
ou un patient qui n'a pas complètement
éliminer le virus voient éventuellement
réapparaître les symptômes c'est un
exemple où l'infection ne semble pas
s'être comporté de façon atypique et on
doit étudier des cas tels celui ci à
fond pour en savoir plus l'autre
puisqu'elle se croyait immunisées schyle
en gare ou s'ils s'apprêtaient à aller
prêter main-forte des individus dans le
besoin s'en douter qu'elle aurait pu
continuer à transmettre le virus se
demande si les directives de santé
publique pour les personnes infectées
devraient être révisées on en apprend
tous les jours donc on met en place des
ces consignes de santé publique qui
semble être approprié compte tenu des
connaissances qu'on a en place un moment
donné si les connaissant changé bien sûr
que les concerts vont changer dossier
shi lang a aussi espère elle que des cas
comme le sien puisse aider les autorités
à mieux cerner les risques de ce virus
qui nous réserve encore bien des
surprises ici frédéric zajac radio
canada vancouver